what's up reject nation
we're gonna watch how it should have
ended been a while since we watched a
hizzy video how the batman should have
ended dance there's justice i was gonna
say that you're just getting always
you're like a child it's like let me
speak let me just why don't you just shh
that was not how the intro was supposed
to go
[Music]
who the heck are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance
i thought his name was batman yeah me
too i am batman but you said your name
was vengeance because i'm also vengeance
it's just really confusing you dress
like a bat you have this spooky bat
signal in the sky and then someone asks
you who are you and you say i'm
vengeance because i'm vengeance and
batman
how did the name vengeance come into
play in this movie that moment right
there i guess did he name himself
vengeance or did the public name him
vengeance and then he decided to adopt
the name vengeance he eventually
realized that no matter how hard you try
to choose your own nickname the court of
a public opinion always wins you can see
the bad eyes in the batman
[Laughter]
googly eyes
hey batman what's up
why don't you come over so i can know
your secret identity
shut up nothing
you're not even supposed to be here
uh-huh
it was kind of creepy that's it yes
[Music]
i've been trying to reach you let me
guess
my car warranty is about to expire
that's not why i called get lost spammer
that was a riddler not a scam
yeah just like the batman
yes yes yes
i'm bruce wayne
i just came to party
that it's so true every time i watch
this movie whenever i watch them like
this face would have been incinerated
yes every single time i watch it now i
just can't help us here that is one of
the best jokes i've seen about that i'm
not going to be able to to not think of
that
eyes and mouth anymore when i walked
into that point in the movie for your
most realistic grounded interpretation
of batman his skin cannot be
penetrated by fire biggest plot hole in
the movie who are you under there
what are you hiding are you just
hideously scarred
[Laughter]
i love it i love it
style watch out for the
turning into a bat
you wanna know
how i got these stars because you're the
batman because i'm the batman
[Music]
for some reason i can forgive that
moment he's here for the movie
i think you've broken every bone in my
body
oh yes so true how is so funny i love
the commitment to him so being gone andy
circles will never live that down ever
that is something too like this is so
brilliant because every time i re-watch
it my nitpick brain does go off a little
bit that's obviously from the riddler he
he ought to know that right you've been
breaking these ciphers like half the
movie yeah you know that there's
probably something dangerous in that
envelope right you maybe should be
opening that right up maybe save it
until bruce gets back
you're the best person in the best
position to be able to do that
[Music]
you don't think this hurts me
no but this will cha
yeah that hurts me and so will this
leader ah
you're too late honey you shot him what
took you so long anyway i had to change
out of my suit to break in
and then put my suit back on
after when i got inside
it was this whole thing well
at least falcone is done
any minute
[Laughter]
into the light
you have the right to remain silent
anything you say can and will be used
against you in a quarterback bruce
bruce
it's been like two hours dude shut up
you're not even supposed to be here
[Music]
all right here we go
what is that some kind of pry tool
it's a murder weapon he killed mitchell
with it why did he want you to find it
is that another clue this card says my
confession but that seems too simple
right
there's got to be a reason
does anyone here know what this tool is
called
oh that that's a tucker
you know for carpets
we found the map to all your truck bombs
let's talk to that real quick so no
explosions for you i'm afraid no
no no no
so i saved you
well technically we saved it it took a
lot of people working together to round
up all those bombs and to catch all of
written no i saved it
b
do you know why
because i'm vengeance
so you haven't learned any lessons about
becoming a symbol of hope what
why i'm a symbol for awesome i don't
understand
i guess i can be the symbol of hope i
mean i got hope written on my chest
already so that makes sense so what's
next i don't know
probably fight the joker again or
something oh please don't why not
because it's been done no it hasn't it's
been done to death you wash your face
you know i'm right
you're not even supposed to be here
[Laughter]
that is such a good point well done what
you got a lot of cats
why
do you like eat them or something what i
don't know some people like to eat cats
apparently i don't understand it but
when i said i don't like to eat cats
everyone freaked out so i just thought
maybe i finally met someone who eats
cats
and we'll just run around
sorry that was just really bugging me
you got all these past due pills laying
around i mean
you really might want to consider
conserving your electricity
i think you should leave now
talking to us because batman identifies
that as a murder weapon but he doesn't
bother to ask what exactly is this yeah
what exactly is this
case closed
but the second he found out what it was
he was like i gotta check underneath
the actual movie and the whole time he
never bothered to go what is this weapon
and you know batman would normally
bother to find out what the what this
thing exactly is well and he's got the
guy who's later on going to tell him
exactly so it's like it could have
easily uh been wrapped up in that scene
the scene where i always think of
because i mean is from the scene when
he's beating the one guy who the riddler
goon they just like pounding him to
death after infecting himself and he
turns around he's like
recording taps them on the shoulder
every time i watch it even from the very
first time i think of
because i'm bad man
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below thank you so much for being
here this was a brilliant been a long
time since i watched a hizzy video let's
not end it without doing a pic
john can you see andrew hayes batman
he's got so many batman like qualities
he's a big guy
tall
very buff and strong
brooding all the time never smiles you
know he's always out in the streets in
the rain just getting into fights and
tussles
he doesn't have lock picking skills
though it's the one barrier that stands
in the way of andrew hayes batman but i
think that you would be the best one
dude i mean think of it just like
punching people in the knees left and
right and uh you know
breaking codes detecting because andrew
hayes is a smart guy he's an observant
guy you know what i mean g
the best batman in fact revise our
rankings
hey thanks for being here
[Music]